what is success in marketing  number one is to get known you shouldn't  advertise first you should get known  first so if i spend a dollar in  marketing or branding i i don't need my  dollar back it's when you have a toilet  you buy a business and you get a hey we  should put a bathroom in our business  how many of you have a bathroom at your  business what's the roi on that there's  no roi on that how many of you have an  air conditioner and a heater at your  company what's the roi i mean does that  get you customers the air conditioned  sends you customers some things you need  to do because you're in business when  did you start making sense of not  getting known there is nothing more  important than getting known if you if  you can't get known you can't be in  business if i don't know you i will not  do business with you